siete rilassati
beati voi non c'è da allora come potete
vedere la mia storia comincia da una
fotografia mi trovavo sul monte brento
vicino ad arco sotto di me c'erano mille
metri di vuoto senza scorciatoie
ero lì assieme a due miei carissimi
amici luca e michele per un contest
internazionale di fotografia
d'arrampicata che mi chiedeva di portare
quattro immagini che poi sarebbero state
valutate assieme avevo da così tanto
tempo in mente una fotografia che delle
altre tre diciamo se non importava poi
molto la la competizione è una cosa
secondaria
eppure nel momento in cui ho scattato
questa fotografia non ero per niente
soddisfatto e forse era già anche troppo
tardi perché il sole sarà alzata aveva
lasciato aveva insegnato la parte
superiore della parete lasciando un
baratro nera sotto di sé e stato in quel
momento in cui forse per fortuna con la
luce stessa luce che mi attaccava la
vista
vedevo un'azienza un centinaio di metri
più in là sila sulla mia sinistra
sentivo che forse valeva la pena andarli
a vedere come sarebbe cambiata la
prospettiva già già mi maledico perché
non avevo portato una corda statica in
più con la quale a calarmi in quel punto
in sicurezza
infatti il bosco in quel punto
sull'azione monte brento era molto
ripido ricoperto di fogli a loro volta
le coperte da rugiada della della
mattina stessa
allora camminavo facendo attenzione le
scarpe consumate delle mie scarpe
iniziando di non fidarmi mi aggrappavo
ai pochi rami che c'erano fino a che non
sono arrivato a sbalzo sulla parete e ho
dovuto iniziare a disapplicare delle
rocce cercavo di non tirar le ma di
prenderle verso il basso con le mani con
i piedi per fare in modo di appunto non
è stare queste rocce da quel tenero bush
di terra che le custodiva in 5 10 minuti
era arrivato su quell azienda
io sono qui dentro quel puntino rosso e
non ho mai fatto vedere questa
fotografia mia nonna scusa
mi voltavo e luca michele erano ancora
lì a che stavano aspettando una mia
indicazione è proprio in quel momento è
avvenuto quello che speravo sulla cima
del monte brento vedevo la sagoma di due
best jumpers io non sapevo chi loro
forse roma sapevo che forse li avrei
trovati lì il tempo di un salto nel
vuoto e 7 frame al secondo
nel momento in cui ho visto uno di quei
sette frame sullo schermo lcd la mia
fotocamera
inutile dirvi che mi sono commosso mi
sono sentito vivo e poi un paio di ore
più tardi mi sono reso conto che quel
gesto il prendersi quel rischio forse
era stato qualcosa di veramente inutile
e allo stesso tempo mi sono domandato è
stata proprio l'inutilità di quel gesto
a render quel momento così importante
così intenso
eppure l'inutilità dicono che non abbia
una forma un valore né tantomeno un fine
però per me per un secondo aveva
significato tutto guardando questa
fotografia penso che molti di voi vedano
quattro persone in uno spazio indefinito
quasi un'immagine vuotano eppure il
giorno in cui ho scattato questa
fotografia ci trovavamo in una tempesta
di neve e la presenza della natura era
talmente forte che non avvertivi un
senso di mancanza un vuoto sentivi
questa presenza che ti avvolgeva e che
in un certo senso proprio ti riempiva
l'anima perché vi dico questo sapete noi
esseri umani diamo il significato una
parola attraverso l'esperienza che ne
facciamo
ovvero il più delle volte e l'esperienza
stessa il significato che diamo una
parola
avete mai pensato che significato diamo
la parola utilità
sfogliando velocemente un dizionario
scopriamo che un oggetto nazione un
pensiero viene definito utile nel
momento in cui ho ha uno scopo o in
termini economici che è un valore
lì mi sono domandato andare oltre
l'utile il convenzionale l'imposto è
davvero così inutile come crediamo
oppure è proprio porre l'utilità come
scopo finale il nostro vero limite
c'era una persona cioè perché ha tuttora
vivo una persona che aveva da dire la
sua su questa cosa
si chiama ivan scinardo ivo cynar p per
chi di voi non lo conosce è un alpinista
un surfer un imprenditore statunitense
il buon scinardo in una delle sue più
famose citazioni una volta disse
arrampicare uno sport inutile si diventa
conquistatori dell'inutile in vetta ci
si può arrivare in molti modi ma il come
e il come essere importante ebbene penso
che qua nessuno di noi in questo
bellissimo teatro spenderebbe il proprio
tempo per fare qualcosa di inutile
ovvero sprecherebbe la risorsa per
definizione è finita e per noi più
importante per forse così sprecarla
mandarle un utilità sapete io penso che
noi esseri umani come uomo moderno
abbiamo due problemi principali il primo
è che troppo troppo spesso confondiamo
le parole di utilità e felicità pensiamo
che sia la stessa cosa ne pensiamo che
essere felici sia fare tante cose
in poco tempo e perché no con un
profitto per me allucinante
nel senso che così facendo qualsiasi
cosa che si estrae dalla nostra sfera
lavorativa
la definiamo di conseguenza inutile il
secondo problema che non so nemmeno io
se sia più o meno grave del primo è che
così facendo non arriviamo più a fare
quello che vogliamo
quello che desideriamo nel profondo ma
facciamo quello che ci conviene e il più
delle volte o cene pentiamo o ce ne
lamentiamo
sapete se vi dico questo perché penso di
averlo vissuto in prima persona in uno
dei momenti più importanti nella vita di
ognuno di noi
ovvero durante l'istruzione infatti io
mi sono iscritto liceo scientifico
perché pensavo che il diploma in in quel
tipo di scuola mil tornasse più utile in
un futuro
conscio di questo ho deciso di rincarare
la dose e frequentando università come
quella di economia non perché mi
piacesse veramente ma perché pensavo mi
lasciasse avete presente quel ampio
ventaglio di possibilità future già mi
vedevo lavorare in banca e o saltavo
lezione per andare arrampicare o quelle
poche volte che mi si presentava
arrivato col mio zaino carico di
attrezzature a corde tutto il resto è
pronto per scappare e forse due fogli
con cui prendere appunti sapete la
scuola l'università l'istruzione sono
dei veri e propri doni che la società si
dà per diventare uomini liberi persone
migliori capaci di ragionare con la
propria testa
io questa cosa purtroppo la scoperta
quando forse era un po troppo tardi
ma sapete come sono diventato comunque
un uomo libero
una persona migliore paradossalmente
attraverso la cosa più irrazionale e
quindi più comunemente inutile seguendo
tutto il ragionamento ha seguito le mie
passioni
io di lavoro faccio il fotografo e
filmmaker outdoor che cosa significa
letteralmente fotografo persone atleti
da fuori per lo più montagna
il mio non è un lavoro propriamente
convenzionale come potete vedere perché
mi piace stare a peso con la mia corda a
grandi altezze e forte esposizioni il
presupposto per essere un fotografo e
filmmaker outdoor e saper si muove
nell'ambiente in cui si va a fotografare
ovvero di saper raggiungere un luogo il
più delle volte molto più importante che
la fotografia stessa
la fotografia e l'arrampicata mi hanno
accompagnato ormai negli ultimi dieci
anni della mia vita
prima la fotografia attraverso che
attraverso un regalo che mio padre mi
fece per aver dei ricordi poi arrivata
subito dopo l'arrampicata in una torrida
giornata d'estate ancora me lo ricordo
su una parete che brulicava di scorpioni
un'esperienza che così sconsiglierei a
chiunque di avere
eppure quel giorno mi sentivo nonostante
avessi paura e facessi fatica mi sentivo
libero quasi invincibile e da quel
giorno è ovvio che non ho più smesso
la fotografia l'arrampicata sono nate
per caso e si sono unite in maniera
inscindibile sempre per caso
tanto che se dovessi scegliere una o
l'altra probabilmente rinuncerà ad
entrambe la fotografia per me e
l'arrampicata soprattutto l'arrampicata
è stato un modo per scoprire la montagna
in tutte le sue sfaccettature
per capire per vederla nel suo ciclo
delle stagioni nella nel suo modo di
evolversi
l'unica costante rimaneva la macchina
fotografica nel mio zaino partivo da
casa verso qualsiasi luogo che invece mi
facesse sentire a casa fosse una falesia
in spagna o le però le pareti delle gole
del verdon una cresta sul monte bianco o
la prima high line al mondo su di old
men of astori in scozia sull'isola di
skye oggi con questa faccia stanca mi
rivedo un po come ivan scinardo nel mio
piccolo mi vedo anch'io un conquistatore
dell'inutile ricerche momenti nel
presente come attimi più importanti
nella mia vita
ricerco il mio inutile per citando
messner mai me ne voglia
non sentirmi morire dentro la montagna
mi ha insegnato tantissime cose mi ha
insegnato l'importanza di essere
invisibile di l'importanza di non
lasciare nessuna traccia se non
l'impronta dei miei passi la montagna
stava e sta tuttora l'immobile io mi
muovo grato su di essa
sapete la natura nel momento in cui ti
apre le braccia non ti chiede nemmeno di
rispettarla però nel momento in cui
riesce ascoltarla in silenzio sviluppi
una sensibilità tutta nuova
una responsabilità prima verso 7 stesse
poi riesce a restituirglielo la cosa che
mi piace di più delle montagne che
riesco a vederla come la dimensione di
collegamento tra il finito e l'infinito
cioè la cima delle montagne il punto più
alto che possiamo raggiungere per
arrivare quasi a toccare a vedere una
realtà che non nemmeno più la nostra
dove non esiste nemmeno più il valore
del tempo la fotografia mi ha segnato
tante altre cose
ho iniziato a fotografare per avere dei
ricordi e poi si è voluta in un modo in
cui mi chiedeva di fotografare solamente
quello che credevo più bello a sorridere
perché dicono che non esiste niente di
più inutile dell'arte
eppure dicono anche che in natura non
esiste niente di inutile nemmeno
l'inutilità stessa oggi fotografo per
vivere a raccontare storie perché è di
storiche siamo fatti tutti noi insieme
l'arrampicata e la fotografia ma ne ha
insegnato il valore intrinseco di
utilità dell'inutile oggi se sono qua
non è per dirvi cosa dovete dovreste
fare vorrei lasciarvi un messaggio che
però sia la mia parte più sincera
cerchiamo il nostro inutile
cerchiamo quella cosa che ci faccia
sentire vivi perché l'inutile l'unico
mezzo che abbiamo per misurare il nostro
tempo la nostra felicità qualunque esso
sia
nel momento in cui avremo trovato il
nostro inutile saremo in grado di
condividerlo penso veramente che potremo
essere felice è in quel momento che il
nostro inutile diventerà utile perché
azioni fine a se stesse sono l'unico
modo che abbiamo non solo per elevarsi
spiritualmente come individui ma anche
per una crescita civile e culturale
collettiva di tutti noi
quindi la domanda è
siete pronti a cominciare a conquistare
il vostro in utile grazie grazie trento